Ich glaube aber, dass ich gewonnen habe.
Und man hat das schon immer schon gemerkt.
Mein Name ist Toolzion.
Ich bin ein Tierarmt.
Und was gibt es an der rechten Seite?
viljanуч
timer
pus
Ich we granting wood for the tree
Ja Stripes, kanns bei dem bleiben was drin steht. Wir müssen heute echt mal den Kram ein bisschen weitermachen, sodass er funktioniert.
Vielleicht machen wir heute auch das mit der Waage.
Gibt's Gewicht Reveal.
Ja, check mal ICQ. Das gehört jetzt irgendwelchen Cacomodates, ne? ICQ.
So, mal kurz die VM anschmeißen. Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, die VM. Die sagen ja nicht VM, die sagen VM.
Hast du schon mal Online-Werbung geschaltet?
Ich glaub nicht. Mir fällt jetzt zumindest nichts ein, wo ich schon mal Online-Werbung geschaltet hätte.
Max, du hattest mich gestern mit dem gefakten Ping-Icon.
Was?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was du meinst.
Is even api tells you? So was gibt's ja.
Das ist aber ein April-Scherz, oder?
Das ist doch ein April-Scherz. Es ist aber ein lustiger April-Scherz. Sollte das kein April-Scherz sein, dann ist das ziemlich dumm.
Aber die Seite ist genauso gemacht, wie diese ganzen Start-Up-Seiten eben alle aussehen.
Aber die Idee ist lustig. Wobei ich sagen muss, gestern die meisten Witze waren total langweilig.
Ja, langweilig. Alle haben sie irgendwie geschrieben, weil es Linus Tech-Tips vollgemacht hat.
Alle haben sie gesagt, ha ha, ich habe jetzt einen Only-Fan-Account.
Ha, lul, lul, lul. Das war mega Paynes-Champ-ig.
Herwing, neun Monate. Dankeschön ins Zapp.
Hast du das mit der VM auch im Gyra? Klar, habe ich das im Gyra vermerkt.
Ich mache privat natürlich alles auch nur noch im Gyra. So früh? Naja, heute ist Feiertag. Ich hätte schon viel früher online sein können.
Aber ich habe... Leute, Chat, Chat, ich muss euch was fragen.
Ja, von ihr habe ich das auch mitbekommen. Und da habe ich gedacht, ey, das ist jetzt schon die zweite, wo ich das gesehen habe.
Dann habe ich auf Twitter mal geschaut und der Witz ist total, total alt. Also von den beiden habe ich es auch mitbekommen.
So, ich muss euch mal was fragen, Chat. Habt ihr eine Ahnung? Also, bei mir im Garten wurde ein Baum gefällt.
Und ich gebe jetzt nicht einen Baum ein. Ich glaube, ihr wisst alle, wie ein Baum aussieht.
Aber ein ziemlich großer Baum. So was da in der Richtung. Guck, so in... Ziemlich große Tanne war das.
Oder ich glaube zumindest eine Tanne. So, und die haben wir gefällt oder haben wir fällen lassen.
Hast du einen Antrag zum Baumfällen gemacht? Ja, ja, habe ich. Das ist in Deutschland so krass bürokratisch, der ganze Scheiß.
Aber ja, ich hatte einen Antrag zum Baumfällen und der liegt auch schon ein paar Wochen rum jetzt. Das ist nicht ganz neu.
Ich habe das Problem. Ich finde, ich weiß nicht nach, was ich suchen muss.
Ne, für den musste ich keinen Ausgleichsbaum pflanzen, weil der war so groß. Den mussten wir aus Sicherheitsgründen abmachen, dass es nicht beim Nachbar aufs Haus fällt.
Da musste ich keinen Ausgleich pflanzen. Zumindest, was ich für ein Problem habe, ist, wie heißen Handwerker oder Unternehmen, die sowas entsorgen oder abtransportieren oder was auch immer.
Was muss man da suchen? Ich finde keinen, der diesen Scheißbaum abholt.
Sägewerk? Nein, Quatsch, ein Sägewerk macht das doch nicht.
Grünabfälle-Entsorgung. Ok, zeige ich mal her. Grünabfälle-Entsorgung.
Kompostieranlage, hallo. Das reicht wahrscheinlich nicht für den Baum.
Also ich suche jemanden, der das für mich macht. Macht das nicht die Firma, die den Feld nicht zwangsläufig, ne?
Baum, was? Baumdienst? Gibt es?
Baumdienst?
Nee, das ist irgendwas anderes, oder?
Ich will Entsorgung. Baumchamp programmieren, ja?
Rund um den Baum in Röder, das ist gar nicht so weit weg. Rund um den Baum, zeigt mal her.
Laufach ist auch nicht weit weg. Groß-Gerau ist ein Stückchen weg.
Ok, was machen die? Guck mal, die haben schon mal einen Plan.
Die wissen, was sie machen. Jetzt plus die Frage, ob die auch Entsorgung machen.
Entsorgung, guck mal hier, Poggers.
Ich habe diese Fehlermeldung legit noch nie gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt.
Da habe ich mir jetzt ein Virus eingefangen. Gleich mal hier Prozess-Explorer checken.
Virus von der Baumschule.
So, was haben wir hier? Was läuft hier? Sieht da irgendwas verdächtig aus?
Ja, sieht alles normal aus. Unsinnigste Tool überhaupt, aber gut.
Die Webseite ist braun. Der Typ soll ja auch mal einen Baum entsorgen und keine schöne Webseite haben.
Warum ist die Webseite eigentlich braun, zeigt mal her.
An was stört er sich denn? JQuery. Ah, JQuery kann er nicht downloaden.
Weil, Moment, weil, JQuery in 2021, weil musecdnbusinesscatalyst.com nicht auflösbar ist.
Das scheint mir eine absolut high-end pleading edge Webseite zu sein von dem Kerl.
Aber ist mir egal, solange er den Baum ordentlich machen kann.
Guck mal, der hat sogar einen YouTube-Channel. Die sind mal hier modern.
Oh, das ist natürlich toll. Sechs Jahre, er hat drei Subscriber.
Ey, an den ihrer Stelle würde ich nicht so viel Werbung machen für sich, weil die Webseite ist auch nicht die beste.
Okay, machen die jetzt immer noch Bäume weg? Moment, Leistung, Entsorgung, genau. Ah, diese Kackseile.
Okay, also was machen sie? Grünschnitt, Stammholz, ja wunderbar, die brauche ich. Die müssen meinen Baum wegbashing, Alter.
Gut, das ist doch schon mal nice. Die können wir schon mal nehmen. Was haben wir da sonst noch so? Der Baumdienstgerber. Was machen die? Machen die Entsorgung, Leistung, Baumfällung, Pflege? Machen die auch inklusive Entsorgung?
Siehste, die machen, die entsorgen nichts. Entsorgung? Okay, die machen das auch.
Okay, also Baumdienst muss ich so einen Baumdienst zum Baumentsorgen? Alles klar. Wow, die Webseiten werden ja immer... Ach du Scheiße. Was sind das für Webseiten? Hilfe.
Okay, die sollen meinen Baum schrotten, nicht? Leistung. Okay, Baumfällung? Die haben nichts von Entsorgung stehen. Egal, egal. Der Typ macht einen guten Eindruck hier im Pressum.
Oh Gott, was für eine Seite. Wo ist denn der hier? Rödamark? Das ist nicht so weit weg. Okay, die Webseite wurde designt von denen. Die muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Naja, coming soon. Ich hab so meine Zweifel, dass das soon, aber... Okay, die muss ich mir mal merken. Die muss ich fragen. Habt ihr Erfahrungen damit? Hat da mal jemand erfolgreich irgendwelche Handwerker drüber gefunden?
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich nicht mal da was reinstellen soll. Achtung, Flashbang. Auf keinen Fall? Warum nicht?
Scam? Warum nicht? Okay, gut. Chat hat mir schon mal weitergeholfen. Jetzt weiß ich zumindest halbwegs, nach was ich suchen muss.
Ich sollte mal vielleicht das Mikrofon ins Gesicht hängen und nicht hier irgendwie sonst wo rumhängen haben. Kann man mal Baumentsorgung so viel falsch machen?
Ähm, ja. Das Problem ist, du musst jemand finden. Das ist nicht so einfach. Das mit den Baumfällen war nicht so schwierig. Das haben wir ganz gut gemacht, weil der Nachbar hat auch was machen lassen gerade und die hatten da Leute da. Aber...
Beim Entsorgen? Ich finde keinen, der meinen Baum entsorgt. Also der Baum ist schon gefällt, ne? Ich brauch niemand, der meinen Baum fällt. Der Baum ist schon gefällt. Ich brauch jemand, der das Holz wegmacht und die Äste und das ganze Zeug, was im Garten liegt. Das ist ein relativ großer Baum. Mir ist das egal. Der kann das auch zu Feuerholz machen und bei sich im Kamin verheizen. Hauptsache, er nimmt's mit.
Warum haben die den nicht mitgenommen? Weil die da keinen Bock drauf hatten und das nicht mit ihm ausgemacht war.
Und was? 35 Jahre später ist dann der Baum weg, oder wie? Ist der Baum, ist das der Baum, aus dem YouTube stellts? Kann sein, dass man den da auch gesehen hat, ja. Achso, ja. Genau, also wenn ihr den Baum mal sehen wollt, ich kann euch den Baum zeigen.
Ähm...
Zack? Der da. Der da. Aber man sieht's halt jetzt nicht, so weil ich nach unten filme.
Der hier. Also der dahinter. Ah, guck mal, guck mal. Okay, man erkennt nicht so wirklich viel, ne? Aber man sieht schon, der war ganz schön hoch. Das sind jetzt noch andere, die stehen alle.
Ja... Guck, hier sieht man's. Das ist der Baum, das ist der Baum. Der Baum ist gefällt, der liegt jetzt hier so da. Also in Stücken, ne? Nicht komplett. Und...
Das ist, also dieses komplette Ding hier, also dieses komplette Feld hier bis hier ist voll mit Baum. Anzünden, wenn einer kommt, sagst du Osterfeuer. Ja, auch exzellente Idee. Ja, genau. Ich seh schon, der Chat, ich hätte den Chat früher fragen sollen. Der Chat weiß Bescheid, ja. Hier isser.
Also ihr seht, das ist schon ein ordentlicher Baum gewesen. Soll das Ganze noch mal im Winter? Massive Winter, stell's. Nee, das ist der andere. Naja.
Ein eBay-Kleinanzeigen, das ist alles so... so merkwürdige Leute. Moin Twinker. Nee, das kann ich nicht, das funktioniert nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr sagt schlechte Erfahrung, okay.
Aber ich muss... also der Typ macht echt einen ganz guten Eindruck hier. Und wen haben wir da noch? Äh, der hier. Die haben einen ganz guten Eindruck gemacht, oder? Nee, fuck. Wer war das jetzt?
Rund um den Baum, die haben einen ganz guten Eindruck gemacht. Rund um den Baum. Guck mal, da kann sich sogar Google Ads leisten.
Glaub mir, eBay-Kleinanzeigen und zu verschenken und die Leute rennen dir die Bude ein. Ja, das sind aber so komische Leute, mit denen will ich eigentlich gar nicht groß interagieren.
Die eBay-Kleinanzeigen, Leute. So, machen die auch Entsorgung? Entsorgung, Entsorgung. Exzellent.
Kein Problem, wir machen das. Er ist fast wie Bob der Baumeister, Alter. Okay, wo sind die? Wie? Wo ist das Impressum? Oh, das ist am Arsch der Welt. Die kommen bestimmt nicht 500km hergefahren, um meine Baumreste zu entsorgen.
Na gut, aber Chat, ich weiß schon mal Bescheid. Wunderbar. Machen wir mal kurz hier die VM an.
Mal kurz Chat lesen, bevor wir überhaupt, probieren wir mal wirklich ein bisschen was auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Gestern habe ich schon mehr geschwätzt, als dass ich was gebaut habe und dabei ist es gar nicht so schwierig, was ich programmieren will.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich noch mal, um was es genau geht.
Nein, das funktioniert nicht. Ich will irgendjemanden, der dafür dann auch wirklich verantwortlich ist, wo ich dann sage, ey, hol ab und der ist halt dann gefälligst dafür zu sorgen, dass nix kaputt geht, dass das Ding alles weg ist, dass das ordentlich gemacht wird und gut ist. Da bezahle ich auch was dafür.
Das ist mir egal, Hauptsache der Baum ist weg. Dafür, dass sie sich den Arsch ablachen, gab es bisher wenig Leute, die Bock drauf haben.
So, gut. Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Ja, gut, das wird mich nicht großartig stören. Das kann mein Fing auch noch einen Monat rumliegen. Das ist wirklich wild.
Ja, mal gucken, mal gucken. Also, ich frage, der Baumprofi, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, rund um den Baum hieß, hörte sich doch ganz gut an. Also auch den Stamm mit ausfrühen, nee, der bleibt da. Das muss nicht sein. Nee, nee, das muss nicht sein.
Ich baue einfach einen, der den Baum mitnimmt, der schon da, also den kleinen gehackten Baum da schon da liegt. Baumchamp, genau.
Also, nochmal als kurze Zusammenfassung, was wir machen.
Ich zeige das nochmal ganz schnell. Also, ich habe ein paar von diesen Sensoren hier am Start. Das ist ein Sensor, der hat Bodenfeuchtigkeit, der ist eigentlich zum Überwachen von Plumenschöpfen, Pots und Beete und sowas.
So, der überwacht Bodenfeuchtigkeit, Mineralen im Boden, hat aber auch einen Temperaturen-Licht-Sensor und ich habe mir gedacht, nachdem mein Kühlschrank oben, der hat manchmal ein paar Probleme, macht komische Geräusche.
Das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt, das ist der Kühlschrank, den man ab und zu mal neu starten muss. Wo ich immer sage, es ist unglaublich, es ist unglaublich, was man mit Reboot alles lösen kann.
So, und was auch immer dieser Kühlschrank macht, ich habe Schiss, dass der mal einen Geist aufkippt und ich es nicht richtig mitbekomme. Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt, ich mache jetzt Big Brain, Taktik.
Ich lege dieses Ding in Kühlschrank, das ist Bluetooth Low Energy, Kühlschrank rebooten, ja, sonst macht er komische Geräusche teilweise.
Ich lege das Ding hier in Kühlschrank und das misst Temperatur und Licht. Wenn Licht an ist, habe ich die Tür vergessen, wenn Temperatur allerdings zu sehr steigt, weiß ich, es stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Das ist eigentlich der optimale Sensor für Kühlschrank.
Ja, nee, der ist noch nicht geroutet, der Kühlschrank.
So, und das haben wir am Start. Was wir den letzten Stream schon programmiert haben ist, dass der das ausliest.
Also sprich, der kann aktuell über Bluetooth, also ich habe hier so ein kleines Board am Start, der kann aktuell über Bluetooth auslesen, Temperatur und Licht. Ich kann euch auch zeigen, dass das funktioniert.
Ähm, wir flashen jetzt erstmal, Flashchamp.
So, Moment, Battery, was macht der da?
Ach, das war mal eine Debug-Ausgabe, Moment, dass ich Schwachsinn, das muss ich doch mal wegmachen. Ich habe da irgendeinen Müll ausgegeben, komplett, komplett bescheuert.
Das war gestern einfach nur zum Ausprobieren. So, aber wie gesagt, ich kann euch sagen, dass das funktioniert, also zeigen, dass das funktioniert und zwar, das kommt auch weg.
Tangle, danke schön für den Prime-Sub. So, und zwar, was der aktuell macht, ist folgendes, der scannt Bluetooth Low Energy Modus, scannt der, ob Geräte irgendwas rausschicken.
Also, das Problem ist nämlich, es gibt zwei, guck hier, hier kriegt man gerade die Werte, das ist ziemlich hell, wo der Sensor liegt, das ist 1119, ich vermute mal, das sind Lux als Einheit, bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher.
Also der Sensor meldet gerade von dem Ding, es ist relativ hell und ab und zu sagt er dann auch mal seine Temperatur, wenn man lang genug wartet.
So, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, diesen Sensor abzufragen und es gibt auch schon ein paar Projekte, die das gleiche machen, wie ich hier programmieren will, nur die machen das nicht so, wie es mir gefällt.
Ansonsten würde ich in dem Fall tatsächlich auch mal was Fertiges nehmen. So, ach guck, hier seht ihr, die Temperatur, 23 Grad ist ja gerade optimal.
So, und es gibt zwei Sachen, wie man den Sensor abfragen kann. Es gibt einmal die rein passive Geschichte, der Sensor schickt alle 30 Sekunden, seht ihr ja auch hier, das schickt alle 30 Sekunden mal so einen Burst von Infos zu einem Sensorwert.
Das macht der Sensor von sich aus, dazu muss man ihn nicht abfragen, also spricht der Sensor, schickt alle 30 Sekunden Infos über Bodenfeuchtigkeit, über Temperatur und über Licht.
So ungefähr alle 30 Sekunden, seht ihr ja hier unten auch, guck jetzt wieder Temperatur dran, 30 Sekunden bis Minute später.
So, und was ich jetzt mache ist, ich scanne einfach nur, ob irgendwas Daten schickt. Das hat den Vorteil, dass ich nicht die Batterie von diesem Sensor irgendwie belaste.
Ist ja logisch, wenn ich einfach nur das mitschneide, was der Sensor schon schickt, dann verbrauche ich keine extra Batterie.
So, die zweite Variante ist das, was übrigens auch einige fertige Projekte schon machen, die fragen den Sensor aktiv ab.
So, und das verbraucht Batterie wie Sau. Man muss nämlich überlegen, da ist bloß so eine kleine, was auch immer das ist, 230 mAh Batterie drinne.
Das heißt, der Kram hält nicht lange, wenn man den permanent abfragt.
So, deswegen habe ich mir das überlegt, wir machen das folgendermaßen, wir scannen rein passiv die Werte, die reinkommen.
Das haben wir schon gemacht, das funktioniert auch.
Das ist vielleicht nicht schön, aber es funktioniert, das ist das Wichtige. Ob das für Schönheitspreis, muss ich ja gar nicht gewinnen.
Dafür ist C++ an sich schon zu hässlich, das kann man gar nicht schön machen.
Allerdings eine Sache, die mir nicht gefällt und ich will so das Beste aus beiden Welten verbinden.
Nämlich, ich will...
Kann man denn den automatischen Broadcast am Gerät ausschalten? Nein.
Du hast keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie Settings daran zu ändern. Das wäre auch eine Variante, das könnte man auch machen.
Aber es geht halt nicht. Aber wie gesagt, ich will das Beste aus beiden Welten verbinden.
Ich möchte nämlich den Broadcast mitschneiden per Bluetooth, also das, was ich hier mache.
Aber in dieser Ausgabe ist kein Batteriestatus drin. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viel in der Batterie noch drin ist.
Und deswegen...
Big Brain, habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen das so.
Wir scannen passiv, was reinkommt. So.
Und dann merken wir uns, welchen Sensor wir gefunden haben.
Und diesen Sensor fragen wir einmal alle 5 Stunden aktiv die Batterie ab.
Und dann habe ich das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Oder einmal am Tag oder so, mal gucken, weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Dann habe ich nämlich das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Ich habe Batterie in einem größeren Abstand, was allerdings...
Also ich habe den Stand der Batterie in einem größeren Abstand, was aber selbst die Batterie nicht beeinflusst.
Das heißt, als nächstes muss ich gucken, wie kriege ich Batterie abgefragt.
Natürlich habe ich schon mal im Vorfeld ein bisschen...
Ich mache den ganzen Kreml hier mal zu.
Ups, ein bisschen viel.
Oh, da ist wieder der Baumofant.
Ich habe auf GitHub schon mal ein bisschen geguckt.
Und wenn man hier nach ESP32 Flora sucht, findet man ein Beispielprogramm.
Hallo?
Shithub, genau.
Richtig genau, ByteStrike, so sieht es aus.
Dark Reader, was ist denn los?
Leute, wir brauchen keinen Dark Modus.
Sorry, für Flashbang Modus, der Dark Reader nervt gerade rum.
Piss dich, Dark Reader.
Genau, und hier habe ich ein Beispiel gefunden, wie man den Batteriestand abfragt.
Also das hier war schon äußerst eklig rauszubekommen.
Nur mal so, was man da machen muss, um überhaupt die Werte rauszubekommen.
Also man muss einen Bluetooth-Scan machen.
Wir verwenden übrigens nicht die Bluetooth-Library, die dabei ist, sondern...
Oder doch, das stimmt nicht.
Wir verwenden die Bluetooth-Library, die dabei ist, allerdings eine etwas neuere Variante davon, die deutlich weniger Flash-Speicher braucht.
Weil ansonsten ist die 1,9 MB für so eine Firmware ratzfatz voll.
Also der Bluetooth-Stack ist huge fat.
Also der ist sowas, der ist...
Kennt ihr diese Pepo-Version mit dem Fast-Foot in der Hand?
So fat ist ungefähr das Ding auf dem Flash.
So, so, in der Richtung, ja.
So, so machen wir das.
Genau, und man macht einen Bluetooth-Scan.
Das ist hier alles ziemlich default.
Der scannt, der hört einfach endlos jetzt, was die Geräte schicken.
Und um die Werte rauszubekommen, ist richtig big brain, was man machen muss.
Das musste ich mir auch auf GitHub abgucken von einem, der dieses...
Der dieses Protokoll reverse-engineert hat von diesem Sensor.
So, und es funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Nur mal so einen ganz kurzen Überblick, was man machen muss.
Man muss sich die ID von dem Gerät holen.
Dann muss man gucken, ob die ID mit diesem Byte anfängt.
Oder besser gesagt, die ID mit diesem Byte entspricht.
Dann muss man die ID von dem Gerät holen.
Dann muss man gucken, ob die ID mit diesem Byte anfängt.
Oder ob die ID mit diesem Byte entspricht.
Das ist die Xiaomi, Xiaomi, Xiaomi, wie auch immer.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Ich meine die hier.
Bluetooth-ID von diesem Gerät.
Und nur wenn das da kommt als ID, will ich überhaupt weiter gucken.
Dann muss ich irgendwelche komischen C++-Dinger machen, weil es C++ ist.
Dann muss ich gucken, ob im dritten Feld von diesem Array...
...das auf 98 Hex steht.
Das vierte Feld, ob da eine Null drin steht.
Wenn nicht, dann ist es schon mal nichts, was ich auslesen will.
Frag mich nicht warum, ergibt keinen Sinn.
Habe ich mir abgeguckt auf GitHub von irgendeinem Typ, der raus bekommen hat, wie dieses Gerät kommuniziert.
Warum auch immer das so ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, man muss das aber so machen.
Dann muss man irgendwelche... Ja, wirklich, too smart.
Du hast noch nichts verpasst. Mir haben keines eingefallen.
So, dann musst du hier ein paar Sachen checken.
Und im Zweifelsfall, wenn du das nicht auslesen kannst, wieder rausgehen.
So, dann hier nächste Magic.
Wenn das auch... Wenn es Capabilities hat, was auch immer das bedeutet, in dem Fall, keine Ahnung.
Dann müssen wir bei Index 12 anfangen, ansonsten bei Index 11.
Weil, also wie gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber es ist so.
So, und dann muss man sich irgendwie rausholen, wie lang der Wert ist, den man auslesen will und wo er startet.
Und dann kann man das Ganze auslesen.
So, so kriegt man die Temperatur raus.
Und so, also mit so einer äußerst trivialen Zeile, die natürlich jeder auf den ersten Blick versteht,
kriegt man raus, wie der Helligkeitssensor gerade, was der Helligkeitssensor gerade meldet.
Also, ich muss euch sagen, ich verstehe zwar, was das prinzipiell von der Syntax her, was diese Zeile macht.
Aber so genau vorstellen kann ich es mir nicht.
Also, das hier ist ein Zugriff auf den Index Value Start plus 3, das ist dann in dem Fall, glaube ich, 12. 12 plus 3, 15.
15, 16, 17. Index 17.
So, und das ist, glaube ich, ein Bitwise Left Shift.
Also, mit 16, ich glaube, mit 16 Nullen auf... Nee.
Der Twinkler weiß das bestimmt, der kennt mit so was aus.
Ähm, ist das nach links schieben und rechts 16 Nullen auffüllen?
Irgendwie sowas, das ist irgendwie Bitwise Shift, muss ich jetzt genau gucken, was das für eine Operation ist.
Okay, 16 nach links, nach links shift bedeutet rechts 16 Nullen auffüllen, ne?
Also, 16 Nullen rechts auffüllen, weil es ja eine 32-Spit-Zahl ist anscheinend.
So, das Ganze dann noch mal machen und hier 8 Stellen, 8 mal Null, also auf den anderen Index auffüllen.
Das Ganze Binary Or machen und dann noch mal ein Binary Or mit dem, was im Start steht.
Ultra Black, schwarze Magie, aber es funktioniert.
Ihr seht Lichtwert und Temperaturwert, das stimmt auch ungefähr.
Hier ist grad 24 Grad oder so drinne, vielleicht am Fenster ein bisschen weniger, wo das liegt, das passt.
Also es kommt ungefähr hin, so plus, minus 1, 2 Grad vielleicht.
Wie Ort man zwei Zahlen? Ganz einfach, indem du die Zahlen als Binary nimmst.
Ah, also, so was.
Dann nimmst du die erste Zahl, sagst... Okay, das ist jetzt dumm, weil das ist geort 111.
Wir müssen das mal ein bisschen anders machen, so als Beispiel.
Okay, wenn du diese Zahlen orst, 111, 1 oder 1 oder 1 oder 1, passt, ist 1.
Null oder Null ist Null, 1 zu 1, so, 1 oder Null ist 1, 1.
Okay, die zwei Zahlen geort werden das hier. Oder, Moment, ja doch, korrekt, korrekt.
So, und mit einem und würde das dann so aussehen.
So, ah, yes, ich weiß.
Das wäre mit einem und, also man könnte auch einen und hier machen an der Stelle, wenn man denn das von der Logik her bräuchte.
Syntaktisch wäre das okay.
So odert man zwei Zahlen, wie auch immer man das genau mathematisch korrekt bezeichnet.
Und jetzt, um komplett mein Mind zu plonen, wisst ihr wofür die Subnet Mask da ist.
Warum Netzwerk eine Subnet Mask hat?
Das ist genau dafür, dass du rausfinden kannst, was Netzwerk und was Host ist.
Die machen genau das. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie es genau funktioniert, ob du es oderst oder endest.
Ich weiß nicht, aber zumindest sowas ähnliches macht man mit der Subnet Mask auch, um rauszukriegen, was Netzwerk und was Hostanteil ist.
Also es hat ja auch einen gewissen Unterschied zwischen Netzwerk und Host.
So, und jetzt muss ich gucken, wie lese ich die Batterie aus.
Was ich mir überlegt habe ist, also ich hab mal hier so eine Klasse für den Sensor angelegt zum Datensammeln.
Und ich habe mir überlegt, was wir machen, ist folgendes. Also wir lesen hier aus, also wir gucken hier, ob neue Geräte reinkommen.
Wenn neue Geräte reinkommen, dann schreibe ich die in diesen...
Ich weiß, es ist keine Liste, aber ich sag mal Liste, ja. Dann schreibe ich das in diese Liste rein und merke mir das.
Und dann mache ich hier unten in meiner Hauptschleife, mache ich dann einmal alle 5 Stunden Batterienupdate.
So weit die Theorie.
By the way, warum zählt der da jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit hoch?
Was mach ich denn da?
Ah, das ist die Uptime. Oh guck mal, ich war ja sogar so clever und ich hab ne Uptime dabei gemacht, dass ich sehe in der Ausgabe, ob das noch funktioniert.
Ja genau, das ist der Miflora hier. Exzellent, exzellent.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie mein Batterienstatus abfragt.
Das wird richtig Monka-essig, sag ich euch.
Okay, also, wir machen mal, wir machen da mal...
Also, wir machen da mal sowas, was eigentlich, sowas wie Update Sensor Battery Level oder sowas.
Da muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert. Hier habe ich nämlich ein Beispiel, wie das geht.
Wir schauen uns das jetzt erstmal an.
Also, es gibt irgendwelche ID's für den Batteriestatus, gut.
Irgendes Service ID, okay.
War Tado nicht das Ding, was letztens AWS Probleme hat oder bringe ich das durcheinander, wo die Leute ihre Thermostate nicht verstellen konnten?
Letztens hat irgendwie, hat AWS Probleme gehabt und die Leute konnten ihre Heizung nicht mehr steuern.
Da denke ich mir auch mal, bin ich froh, dass ich den Gramm offline habe.
Stellt euch mal vor, euer Internetzugang geht nicht mehr oder AWS hat Probleme und es ist Winter und ihr könnt die Heizung nicht anmachen.
Mein Real Crazy, das ist schon ziemlich fail, oder?
Oh, hier gibt es jetzt, hier gibt es jetzt Big Brain Erklärung.
192168178.0 slash 24 sagt, dass das Netz 256 Adressen...
Ja gut, das ist klar.
Aber wie macht es das?
Mit einem, wahrscheinlich mit einem und, oder?
Ey, invert, invert und und invert oder wie macht es das?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, wie das funktioniert.
Man muss es inverten irgendwie, glaube ich, habe ich im Hinterkopf, ne?
End, man macht End, End und invert oder sowas macht man, glaube ich, ne?
Ach, keine Ahnung, das wusste ich mal, das habe ich, das brauchst du ja nicht tagtäglich.
Was, gestern Abend hatte MS Probleme mit ihrem DNS und dann ging alles von Teams über OneDrive bis hin zu Xbox Live nicht?
Gip.
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Playstation-Ausfall erinnern von der PS3?
Wo das, wo das, das Lizard Squad war, das doch damals, glaube ich, die wie verrückt Sony gedenost haben?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich gerade drauf komme, irgendwie.
Tado hat eine eigene Bridge, ja, das ist schon mal gut.
Da geht wenigstens der Kram weiter, wenn der Internet ausfällt.
Okay, ich bin schon.
Wir gucken jetzt, wie das funktioniert.
Subnetting in, oh fuck, muss das jetzt wirklich sein?
Jetzt wird es Pains Champ, Leute.
Hallo?
Hier, die Seite geht nicht.
Aber, aber wir können einfach IP-Kalk verwenden, dann steht das da alles drinne.
Wie, nicht installiert?
Ein Moment, IP-Kalk habe ich nicht.
Hau mal, IP-Kalk, beste Versuche.
Da steht es doch drinne. So, IP-Kalk, 192.168.50.0.24.
So, hier erklärt es einem jetzt, glaube ich, wie es funktioniert.
Also, genau.
Address.
Genau, das ist die, das ist, das ist, das ist die, das Netz im Binary.
Moment, nee, das ist nicht das Netz im Binary, das ist die Adresse, also kannst du irgendwie sowas machen.
Genau, das ist die Adresse im Binary.
Das ist die Netmask im Binary.
Wildcard is Cisco, geduldens brauchen normale Menschen net.
Das ist Netzwerk.
So, und jetzt kannst du, wenn du das hier, wenn du das hier,
wenn du das hier ein End machst, ich weiß immer noch nicht, ich weiß immer noch nicht mehr, wie es funktioniert.
Wildcard, das ist die umgedrehte, das ist die umgedrehte Netmask, das ist so ein Cisco Ding, die stehen da irgendwie drauf.
Cisco Leute geben gerne nicht Netmask ein, sondern irgendwie Wildcards, weil Cisco Leute sind, keine Ahnung.
Einfach einen Und machen.
Aber einfach einen Und machen kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Dann kommt wieder, bei einem einfachen Uns würde ich hier überall eine Null rauskommen.
Deswegen, ich bin mir relativ sicher, es war irgendwie invertieren und unten.
Man musste einen Und machen und dann invertieren oder irgendwie sowas.
Ach, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Scheiß drauf.
Xorn, ich kann, ich weiß es echt nicht mehr genau, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, das ist die schöne, das ist die IP-Kalge-Ausgabe.
Na klar, ich würde auch was fertiges nehmen.
Ja.
Gut.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben, dass ich nicht mehr weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Hallo Max, ich wollte dir nur mal sagen, dass du ein großer Teil meiner Jugend warst. Es ist schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast. Lil Pippo, oh das kann ich nicht ausbrechen. Lil Pippo Puss.
Was auch immer, aber ähm.
Ähm, damals hast du mich und Commander Krieger täglich nach der Schule geschaut.
Nice.
Freu mich immer über neue Videos, war mega sad, als du damals plötzlich einfach weg warst von YouTube.
Ich war ja nie wirklich weg von YouTube, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Na gut, im Vergleich zu früher war ich ziemlich wenig aktiv die letzten Jahre.
Ah exquisite, ich sehe hier schon, äh, richtig quickscope Name am Start.
Aber wenn du hier guckst, ich meine ich hab die letzten Jahre nicht viel gemacht, ich war nie weg. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich hab hier einfach diese Jahre kaum was gemacht, ne.
Früher, früher, hier pro Jahr, müsst ihr mal gucken.
Ja, pro Jahr, das hört gar nicht mehr auf sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre, sieben, sieben, sieben, sieben, sieben, sieben, sieben. Ja, ja, ja, total viel.
Und dann irgendwie fünf Videos pro Jahr zwischenzeitlich.
Ups, take weight.
Der Sebaro ist da.
Huge.
huge cute mod himself
Und sebaro was macht das lehramts grill jetzt du hast das jetzt erzählt jetzt jetzt jetzt
Interessiert es mich auch
Aber wenn wenn es da was gebe hättest du es wahrscheinlich schon gesagt
So also wir fangen jetzt mal an wir machen wir kurz gucken uns mal den beispiel beispiel kodra an
Sie kann sich hausarbeiten aus dem arsch ziehen wie keine zweit ist jetzt was gutes oder was schlechtes
Ich ich würde behaupten dass er baro klingt beeindruckt
Ja sebaro das wird schon
Du musst sie einfach von deinen cute mod qualitäten überzeugen dann
Du kannst auch sagen du kannst auch sagen du bist discord admin und mod bei wubblers
das zieht bestimmt wahnsinnig
Ich muss mal gucken ob hetzner noch geantwortet hat auf den letzten drücker
Weil ich bin schon ganz scharf drauf hetzner sell-out zu machen aber ich glaube das war zu kurz vor osten jetzt
Die habe ich jetzt schon gewartet mit
Vor allem das sind immer so so bescheuerte messages die die schicken
Und was haben wir noch einen hier haben noch einen anderen
Alexandra vom der marketing show manager alexandra ist am start
Sie wollen mit irgendeinem video
editor oder so verkaufen oder
was auch
Da so wen haben wir dann sonst noch ein ladung zur kooperation
Ok ein ladung zur kooperation von
wiki
Boang alles klar was gibt es denn da das muss jetzt mal kurz hier was wollen sie was wollen sie kooperieren
Guff
Was ist
Ok das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an ob wir mit denen kooperieren wollen was ist gut nicht kruf gut hieß das
Ach nee guvee guvee oder so
Wo wir oder gov gov
Gov
Warum kann google so komische wörter aussprechen ok ich habe kein sound lull was
led strips aha
led strips inklusive grills auf dem sofa ja da kann ich nicht nein sagen was was home improvement temp
Ok das sieht tatsächlich nach irgendwas aus mit denen man was machen könnte indoor lightning
lighting lightning
led bulbs
home improvement
china korea
china cloud
Du hast recht das sieht aus wie diese 015 tuya light bulbs
Aber das ist auf jeden fall was mit denen könnte man durchaus was machen was bieten sie denn an
Die produkte erfreuen sich größter beliebtheit schreibt sie naja gut
Das das würde ich auch sagen
So gleichzeitig liegen unsere produkte
Auch auf sozialen medien wie youtube tiktok und instagram voll im trend
Nice ich werde ich ich kriege gov lampen und da werde ich zum huge tiktoker
Darfst du schleich werden für ein led projekt machen ja auf gehts gucken wir uns dann gleich auf github an oder die projektseite schick einfach
So es werden neue produkte vorgestellt sind auf meinem kanal aufmerksam und das research team ist aufmerksam geworden auf mein kanal
Ok um einen besseren eindruck hinsichtlich unserer
Produktpalette gewinnen zu können schauen sie doch folgenden link unter amazon an
Ok machen wir
Hallo
Pass auf jetzt kommt irgendwie
Weiß nicht ob ich das haben will ehrlich gesagt das sieht so so china klaudisch aus ja
12 volt led strips das heißt die gehen auch relativ weit
Ohne dass sie an farbe ich halt quasi verlieren aber
Ansonsten erkenne ich da jetzt nicht so
Wir arbeiten moment was wir arbeiten mit führenden calls in verschiedenen bereichen zusammen hat ihr mal eine ahnung was das für eine abkürzung ist
Das ist die視
Jetzt muss ich nicht nur it block kan cettejacko
Sehe ich das richtig?
Key Opinion Leader
Also es ist quasi ein Influencer
Und man ist schon zu cool
Das mehr Influencer zu nennen
Alles klar
Schau mal auf Banggood
Die haben die auch
Ja bestimmt
Banggood hat alles
Die bangen halt
Richtig
Was sind das für Doktorspielchen hier?
Ah
Also gibt's da aber anscheinend nicht
Das ist wahrscheinlich
Das ist genau das gleiche
Was die hier verkaufen
Unter irgendeinem eigenen Label
So was schreibe ich jetzt
Sonst noch
Oh jetzt haben sie ein Video gepostet
Wo einer für sie Werbung gemacht
Hat okay
Okay da gucken wir mal rein
Nee das gucken wir nicht
Wir machen nicht noch mehr Werbung kostenlos
Wir okay
Wir sind überzeugt
Dass unsere Produkte
Wir sind überzeugt dass unser produkt ihnen und ihren fans gefällt chat meint ihr das könnt euch gefallen
Wir freuen uns darauf mit ihnen tolle inhalte zu erstellen falls sie an einer kooperation interessiert sind schreiben sie mir bitte und
Um weitere pläne für eine zusammenarbeit zu besprechen
Ja ich mein fragen kostet ja nix kann ich ja da mal
Nopas ich mache ganz ehrlich ich mach einfach sehr laut ich mach 30 mach 30 ich mach das wieder ich mach das wieder bauer jetzt wieder aua
Ich mache einfach diese 15 20 sekunden
Wollen sie wahrscheinlich sein ja
Ich mach dann einfach 15 20 sekunden werbung rein dieses video ist gesponsert bei
Bei guvi irgendwie bla bla bla led strips bla bla bla ganz tolle super neue technik bla bla bla fertig alles gut it's money
So irgendjemand von werbung für sein led projekt machen
Jonas dankeschön für den zap habe ich nicht über das habe ich habe ich habe ich nicht gesehen aber massive IQs boost wieder für den chat
So wo gibt's wo gibt's werbung für das led projekt hier?
exquisite
self-made ambi light für den raspberry pi ok cool
NG
Das ist quasi das gab es schon mal oder wie
Und jetzt ist jetzt im next next gen
Das heißt das heißt es läuft jetzt auch auf der ps5
Okay, leute ich muss aufhören so super lustige witte zu machen ich weiß aber huge guck mal hier ein kar sterne das ist ja schon ziemlich erfolgreich
Zeigst mal her
Schönes web interface
Schönes web interface auf was was braucht man dafür also respire ganz vergessen
NG ich hoffe nicht dass das ng für angela steht oder
Weil bei angela heißt ja alles ng
Ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden warum
Okay cool das heißt wir funktionieren das weißt du was tp modding weißt du was
Das probieren wir mal aus irgendwann im stream
Was braucht man da alles dafür
Muss man da irgendwie per hdmi sachen abgreifen oder per kamera oder oder wie funktioniert das von der idee her
Weil irgendwie muss es ja an die bild infos kommen
Per usb krabber ok du schließt quasi in usb capture device an und du dann wärtest
Oh das war bestimmt nicht einfach ich stelle mir das kompliziert vor aus dem hdmi stream irgendwas auszulesen
Aber das funktioniert nicht mit hdcp dann
Weil ich gucke beispielsweise auf dem fernseh drüben relativ viel amazon und es wird wahrscheinlich mit hdcp nicht funktionieren
Denke ich mal
Oder hast du kodi auf dem pay nee gar nicht
Ich habe einen nvidia schild und einen otroid hc2 so ein ding
Mit einer festplatte für tv geschichten zum für fernsehaufnahmen so ein teil hier
Ach man kann sich ernsthaft man kann sich hdcp lizenzen kaufen ich dachte für hdcp muss man quasi
Jahrzehntelange lobby arbeit leisten dass das das bekommt
Ja, ju ist aber auf jeden Fall nicht so schlecht wie hdcp
Aber ich glaube das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
Jahrzehntelange lobby arbeit leisten dass das das bekommt ja ju ist aber auch philips dahinter
Die haben damit kein problem die sind nicht in den ich nenne es mal in die entwickler auf github
Alternativ kann man auch irgendwelche hdcp entferner dazwischen schalten die man ja eigentlich gar nicht haben darf
Also ich habe also ich ich kann per hdmi gucken per hdcp und das funktioniert ich habe ja so ein ding hier als es das noch gab
Dreamlite tv nicht dreamscreen habe ich drüben bei mir am am fernseh und das funktioniert mit hdmi leider nur bis bis 1080p
Danach mag es nicht da stimmen die farben nicht
Ambilite mit kodi ist easy ja aber wie gesagt du kriegst den kodi nicht so einfach einfach die videos aus beispielsweise der amazon app rein
Das funktioniert nicht das muss auf tiefere ebene passieren die farben sind wegen hdr nicht wegen 4k
Das kann tatsächlich sein ja aber ich habe kein 4k dreamscreen also der hat probleme mit mit höheren auflösungen
Ich glaube ich habe sogar hdr ausgeschaltet zum ausprobieren
Aber zumindest das ding ist nice das kann das halt auch mit hdr hdcp leider gibt es das nicht mehr die sind pleite gegangen aber es gibt noch ein paar andere sachen
Aber letztendlich wurscht das ist aber eine gute idee das kann man mal ausprobieren
Das kann man mal ausprobieren
Das funktioniert auf dem shield tv nicht richtig du brauchst du musst die offizielle amazon app aufmachen dass es gescheit funktioniert
Ansonsten klar du kannst es noch über den browser machen aber das ist dann auch mehr also ich bin mittlerweile weggekommen davon dass ich überall irgendwie custom lösungen basteln
So leute also wir haben jetzt gelernt ich bin ein influencer ist out ich bin jetzt auch zum col aufgestiegen
Ich bin jetzt quasi influencer und key opinion leader und deswegen mache ich demnächst led sellout easy perfekt mache ich einfach mal
So und jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen sache die wir die ganze zeit schon machen wollen
Genau nämlich gucken wie ich von meinem sensor batterien status auslesen kann
Ja twingo geht mir ähnlich ich will einfach sachen die gut funktionieren
Ich mache es mittlerweile so wenn es was fertiges gibt was so zum größten teil passt dann nehme ich das aber halt auch nur wenn da sonst nichts dagegen spricht
Also ich nehme zum beispiel nichts mit china cloud dann flashe ich das aber am liebsten mit custom firmen aber halt mit irgendwas fertiges was ich nicht mehr selbst programmieren muss
Für so sachen wie das hier erstens habe ich da immer noch spaß dran und außerdem gibt es da nichts fertiges was das so macht wie ich das haben will
Warum juckt es netflix welches gerät ich zum stream verwende
Ja warum gibt es mittlerweile eine allianz zwischen providers und content anbietern um sachen zu blocken wegen stonks und geld
Also ich wollte mir nämlich mal angucken wie der typ hier das macht also es gibt irgendwelche ids so die id für die batterie brauchen wir
Der wifi connect um mqtt juckt mich net disconnect mqtt juckt mich auch net flora klein okay hier können es langsam interessant werden
Okay okay boah ach du scheiße das ist ja mit ach moment ne hier liest ihr die sachen aus die schon ausgelesen habe das ist egal
Battery characteristics ist vielleicht noch interessant okay process flora service process flora device okay okay es ist
Okay process flora device address device mecha dress read battery das heißt hier geht es los
Also wir brauchen eine adresse und wir brauchen eine mech die adresse habe ich die adresse habe ich das ist nämlich das da
Wobei moment ich kann einfach den kompletten sensor übergeben flora sensor sensor weil den sensor haben wir ja da den haben wir hier oben angelegt
So das rufen wir jetzt einfach für jeden sensor auf alle jede sekunde so update battery level und zwar für den sensor muss man das jetzt auch mit
Und übergeben weil es ist ja immer noch 10 plus plus das ist nicht zwangsläufig logisch ja wenn die telekom das auf twitter antwortet ist das natürlich die verlässlichste
Quelle von jemanden dabei ist das ist wie wenn du mich fragst max wer macht die besten videos auf youtube da bin ich sicherlich auch äußerst objektiv ich
Ich meine ich bin am wenigsten so fair und würde sagen möchte ich selbst nennen weil ich das mir zu doof vorkomme aber
Okay also hier kriegen wir jetzt den sensor wie müssen wir jetzt anfangen wir brauchen erst mal wie geht es denn jetzt aus processing die weiß all die das ist debug geblubber das braucht man nicht get flora kleint okay mit get flora kleint geht es los le device create kleint
Okay das ist das einzige was er hier drin macht das kriege ich auch hin wobei wir können einfach auto nehmen nennen wir das mal kleint gibt er nicht viele möglichkeiten
So create kleint exzellent so wie geht es weiter wenn kleint not connect es muss kleint connect machen okay kleint connect und wohin
Max dps der channel den hat deshalb ja das mit max dps war ziemlich doof von mir auf youtube ich wollte ja ich wollte ja overwatch videos machen und ich habe einen neuen channel erstellt für overwatch videos genau dann wo ich aufgehört habe mit overwatch was richtig hängen geblieben ist
Richtig sixhead ja
Ja wahrscheinlich die meisten wobei meine frage macht ich macht es ja öfters mal wer ist von youtube an dem müssen wir umgedreht fragen wer kommt nicht von youtube wer kommt nicht von youtube wir haben ich weiß dass wir mittlerweile schon einige haben die es auch nur über twitch gefunden haben eins
Die eine oder andere gibt es das weiß ich finde ich nice
Ne brauche ich keine umfrage für twitch und wie auf twitch wahrscheinlich über irgendwelche irgendwelche empfehlung unten links ne du kommst von pornhub ja bestimmt von von tanzverbots channel wobei der ist ja gelöscht tanzverbot gibt es ja nicht mehr auf pornhub
Er ist ja oder zumindest die videos gibt es ja nicht mehr wer übrigens nicht wusste dass er den pornhub channel hat leute vergesst einfach was ich gesagt habe ihr müsst jetzt nicht nachgucken das ist eigentlich nicht unbedingt das was man so sehen will
Aber ansonsten zur allgemeinen bildung trägt es ja auch beine man muss ja muss ja bescheid wissen
Auf dem er regelmäßig oder regelmäßig halbwegs regelmäßig porno reviews gemacht hat auf pornhub war ein bisschen merkwürdiges format da saß er quasi halb naggisch mit dem handtuch um und hat siniert über irgendwelche aktuellen pornsachen
Ich weiß auch gar nicht woher warum ich das überhaupt weiß und warum ich das überhaupt geguckt habe ich egal egal
Ich weiß auch nicht wieso guckt man sowas ich weiß es auch nicht ich weiß es auch nicht ich habe das zumindest stückchenweise angeschaut tanzverbot
So aber zur eigentlichen wichtigen sache zurück was muss man jetzt mal muss gucken ob das ganze heute ich muss ich muss den da krieg ich krieg ich werde halb blind wenn ich wenn ich hier umschalte zwischen editor und browser das blendet übelst
Ok get flora klein brauchen was haben wir gemacht und jetzt muss man checken ob das ganze connected ist das ist ziemlich komplizierter check ums auszuprobieren glaube ich
Die groovy elektrik zwitschbein dankeschön für sechs monate subscription massive sub huge subscribers hier wieder warum sind wir noch im just chatting warum nicht passt doch just chatting ist kategorie alles
Und ich habe das gefühl just chatting finden prinzipiell mehr leute als science und technology
So aber jetzt machen wir ein bisschen science und technology wo sind wir stehen geblieben muss das endlich mal was machen also wir gucken jetzt ob das ding connected ist also kann man da jetzt sowas machen wenn das gleich null ist dann was ist eigentlich der unterschied mal die 10 plus plus pros was ist der unterschied zwischen gleich gleich null und gleich gleich null pointer
Und wenn es das gleiche ist warum gibt es da zwei verschiedene dinger keiner okay warum gibt es dann zwei dinger
Das eine ist ein def das andere ist ein keyword aha okay ach moment das ist ein bool if not connected dann machen wir mal eine ausgabe print con failed
Funktion ist jetzt dann return zack
If null gleich gleich null das funktioniert was das geht wahrscheinlich
Okay dann aber uns connected okay was macht er als nächstes
Ganz schön umständlich get flora service macht er dann im prinzip genau der gleiche krempel wie er vorher auch schon gemacht hat also quasi
client get service ach service uid brauchen wir jetzt also sowas hier quasi jetzt können wir mal 10 plus plus sachen verwenden dass er das nur einmal macht so und wahrscheinlich brauchen wir die battery dann später auch noch das triggert mich schon wieder dass das anders geschrieben ist
Der beste z plus plus ist nicht logisch zu hinterfragen ja das ist richtig
Was nicht if not connected if connecting failed wieso ist doch richtig wenn wenn connect nicht geklappt hat dann connect failed oder ist es oder ist es eher ein ein ein grammatik hinweis
Also ich meine if not connected ist eigentlich trifft ziemlich gut was das hier macht so get service das gibt einen pointer zurück okay auto service
So und dann checken wir jetzt wenn das service null ist null dann schreiben wir service failed mein irgendwas muss ich hinschreiben service failed return
Und jetzt ist die frage gibt so was wie disconnect disabo da machen wir das nämlich auch noch davor wisst ihr was jetzt cool wäre
Irgendwas wo man sicherstellen könnte so einen try catch finally oder defer oder sowas aus go wo man sicherstellen könnte oder vielleicht gibt es ja sowas mit z plus plus und ich kenne es nicht
Wo ich sicherstellen könnte dass er immer das hier macht bevor er aus der Methode rausgeht quasi so einen so einen finally block gibt sowas
Nee oder? Wahrscheinlich gibt sowas nicht das ist zu zu advanced dafür
Okay get service da sind wir stehen geblieben blabla something wrong ja blabla wunderbar vielleicht vielleicht schreiben wir noch hin vielleicht schreiben wir noch dass ich das besser debatten kann
Keine connection okay und hier schreiben wir hin service okay wenn du wiss ob der kram dann auch getan hat so was macht er denn jetzt als nächstes
process flora service force flora service data mode aber nicht oder ich weiß nicht was es macht aber wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt massive go to
Das war jetzt ich wollte schon immer ich habe noch nie go to in z plus plus verwendet allein schon weil das das pains champion ist was man angeblich machen kann das war jetzt
Wir bauen das jetzt mit go to einfach nur stop doch wir waren jetzt go to
Aber das sieht man schon mal wieder das sieht man schon mal wieder das go to scheiße ist weil ich kann jetzt nicht sowas machen dann gebe ich am ende nehme ich immer connection failed aus und das will ich gar nicht
Da kann ich wieder da kann ich wieder keine ordentliche fehlermeldung ausgeben weil wenn schon hätte ich sowas machen wollen
Ja ne komm scheiß drauf wir lassen es bleiben Fehler gibt es nicht das ist genauso wie das du weißt ja auch guter code dokumentiert sich selbst
Okay also das im service hat funktioniert was muss man jetzt als nächstes machen process flora service read battery characteristics müssen wir jetzt machen
Read battery characteristics wie funktioniert es jetzt flora service get characteristics und dann die id form von der batterie also hier ist das service okay das service heißt einfach nur service
Und jetzt ist batterie juju id nachdem ich nicht weiß was ich da mache nenne ich es einfach mal so ich habe keine ahnung was das eigentlich genau macht aber
So und jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich wieder gucken ob das null ist ne genau im prinzip der gleiche schmodder wie hier oben nur nicht dafür sondern dafür
Und jetzt machen wir irgendwie char failed was auch immer
Hauptsache char wurde so schön doppeldeutig dass keiner versteht was gemeint ist
So und jetzt
Oh jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt kommt magic value i read value read value okay okay read value value string string value alles klar
Also
Macht er da irgendwas read value
Der redet einfach und dann holt er sich die bytes davon okay
Nennen wir es mal irgendwie battery value hoffe mal dass das funktioniert ich hab ich hab da meine zweifel dass das jetzt gleich beim uploaden irgendwas irgendwas macht so so battery value und jetzt und jetzt aus irgendwelchen gründen was okay das brauche ich net das brauche ich nicht das brauche ich auch
Okay moment was was was was was was was battery value ist im prinzip bei mir das da ach und jetzt kommt der int
Battery level wir gehen hier wir gehen die ordentlichen variable namen aus ist null und und für was ist der crap da unten einfach zum printen ja gut das brauche ich nicht
Vielleicht sollte ich noch checken ob das ob da die länge wir machen das doch anders machen das mal so
Ob da die länge größer null ist oder gleich null also wenn hier die länge
Gleich null ist dann
Read failed danach habe ich das battery level und jetzt kann ich sagen sensor battery level oder battery gleich battery level
So chat wir brauchen eine abstimmung geht es jetzt nachdem ich hoch lade oder nicht
Falls ein mod da ist eine abstimmung machen wir machen mal eine abstimmung ob das funktioniert oder wir können wetter machen ja wir können channel point prediction
Wir können channel point wir machen channel point prediction
Channel point prediction
Mods sind glaube alle wieder afk mod check mod check
Oh ne es geht es geht tatsächlich
Am ende machen wir noch einen disconnect das ist dann auch
Achso und ich brauche noch sensor last battery check
Sp get time
So also prediction
Wer predictet ja was
Funktioniert Fragezeichen Tja
Mal gucken was da rauskommt jetzt bin ich gespannt
Die ist weg
Ich sehe nicht was da rausgekommen ist
Was ist denn rausgekommen
Ist noch da also ich sehe es bei mir nicht 7 und 5 prozent nein
Kurze Idee von dem Projekt also mal ganz kurz ich habe davon ein sensor und davon habe ich ein paar
Und die sind eigentlich dafür da um Blumentöpfe abzufragen Bodenfeuchtigkeit Temperatur Licht und ich habe mir gedacht wir machen das so ich leg das Ding in Kühlschrank
Und ich erkenne anhand des Lichtsensors ob ich die Tür aufgelassen habe und an der Temperatur ob ich ob ich vielleicht Stromausfall habe oder irgendwas mit dem Kühlschrank nicht stimmt
Weil mein Kühlschrank macht teilweise merkwürdige Geräusche und muss manchmal neu gestartet werden und ich hätte gerne Notification wenn das Ding am abtauen ist
Und nachdem das ganze Ding Bluetooth wireless ist
So ok also ja 43 prozent nein 5 prozent
Da fehlt was 25 50 wahrscheinlich
Mein Kühlschrank brauchen eine Reboot ja ok ich mache jetzt nicht weiter wir uploaden jetzt Serial
Wir uploaden jetzt und gucken ob das funktioniert Moment erst ruf ich das überhaupt auf
Ja ok
Also ob das hier funktioniert
Falls ich irgendwie vergessen habe die Funktion aufzurufen oder so dann zählt das weder alles hat funktioniert hat nicht funktioniert dann fix ich das und dann gucken ob es funktioniert hat
So also
Invalid Pair Address
Warum
Ok es funktioniert nicht
Es funktioniert nicht
Warum ok ok warum funktioniert es nicht
Invalid Pair Address 0
Was
Warum ist die Adresse 0
Address
Hä
Hier euch depp hier hätte ich die Adresse übergeben müssen guck mal alles gebastelt und der Fehler sind die ersten Zeile
Ok Sensor
Address ok nochmal ausprobieren
By the way warum kann ich überhaupt einen Client erzeugen ohne eine Adresse anzugeben warum ist das denn überhaupt erlaubt
Einmal beliebt der Grip
Und jetzt
Connection ok Service ok
Connection failed
Service ok
Already exists
Connection already exists wieso ich klausel das doch immer
Ok ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt dass es nicht funktioniert
Ok
Crash
Ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt
Ich darf nicht ich vermute mal ich vermute mal ich darf nicht
Scannen und mich
Gleichzeitig connecten
Ich glaube das geht schlicht und ergreifend in die Hose
Ok machen wir das in it hier
Und den scan hier unten drunter
Scan gut dann scanen wir auch
Wir scanen für 5 Sekunden
Wir scanen alle
Was weiß ich wir scanen alle 200 Millisekunden
Also wir scanen im Intervall für alle 200 Millisekunden 100 Millisekunden lang ok passt Upload
Und das machen wir dann nach einer Sekunde wieder ok
Gibt es nicht immer einen Parameterlosen Constructor in C++
Nee nicht zwangsläufig
Ich kann meinen Constructor private machen da gibt es keinen
Ok
Hat der Upload gerade nicht funktioniert
Warum geht das jetzt nicht
Oh Mensch
Wahrscheinlich ist es wieder was ganz Simples
Und warum crashed er immer erstmal nachdem ich mich neu connected habe
Er weiß es wirklich nicht
Machst du noch was
Reset
Wo ist das jetzt
Ah jetzt ok
Connection ok service ok und jetzt hängt er
What the fuck
Ok
Print also scan start
Ich muss sehen was da vor sich geht scan end
Ich muss ja ich muss ja wissen was was was los ist
Keine facecam null facecam ja ich weiß ich bin bekannt für meine streams mit facecam aber heute habe ich ausgelassen
scan start scan end scan start
Hier ok ok der sagt immer ok und dann was passiert hier
Ok vielleicht funktioniert ja sogar alles ich müsste noch read ok oder sowas sagen
Read ok und jetzt muss ich noch das Batterie das Batterie Level ausgeben
Upload
Ok stimmt ich gebe ja gar nichts aus kein Wunder dass ich nichts sehe
Ist ja eigentlich logisch wenn man nichts ausgibt kann man auch nichts sehen
Huge Schweißheit
Ok Temperatur Temperatur scan scan scan scan end
Hier Batterie 99 ok es ist gedroppt letztes mal
Ach nee das ich hab mich selbst gebadet die Meldung die wir heute Morgen reingeschrieben haben
Batterie 100% die war ja hardcoded 100% die Batterie war ja die richtigen Batteriewert habe ich ja nie auslesen
Aber was ich jetzt gerade so richtig realisiere ist das auslesen funktioniert Leute
99% mir ist es sogar lieber wenn da 99% steht dann weiß ich nämlich dass das prinzipiell funktioniert
Was hältst du von Low Code was ist denn Low Code
Ich kenne nur Big Brain Code
Ok es funktioniert wir kriegen den Batteriewert
Allerdings ich muss aufpassen wenn ich das jetzt noch eine Weile mache ist die Batterie
Was hat der hier überhaupt für Schmerzen wenn ich das jetzt noch eine Weile mache ist die Batterie leer
Meine Stimme hat sich nur geändert das liegt wahrscheinlich daran
Dass ich schon so alt war als ich mit YouTube angefangen habe
Dass ich mit meiner Stimme nichts mehr großartig ändert
Zumal ich ja mehr oder weniger die gleiche Hardware habe immer noch
So scan gab es da noch so wie reset oder sowas
De-init gab es da ne gab es auch nicht was gibt es denn da
Erase Erase klingt gut macht das macht Erase
Delete Per Device ne ne aber Clear irgendwas mit Clear habe ich gesehen Clear Results passt
Ein bisschen Speicher ein bisschen Speicher freigeben
Wir geben hier oben mal am Anfang der Schleife aus
Wie viel Speicher wir frei haben ich will wissen wie viel das belegt
Weil ich weiß dass dieser ganze
Ich weiß dass dieser ganze Kram doch ziemlich viel Speicher frisst
Free hier schauen wir mal
Gute Frage Wer sind da immer noch die Top 3 Host in Deutschland von Preis Leistungsverhältnissen
Was hosten für was fertige Services VMS Hardware
Co location wer host also was willst du gehostet haben
VMS wahrscheinlich
Minecraft Server VMS ja also eine VMS
Dann auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht Amazon nicht Google und nicht
Azure Azure also und auch nicht Azure
Ganz ehrlich
Ich würde sagen am einfachsten ist es tatsächlich immer noch
Pricing von der Hetzner Cloud was aber auch echt billig ist
Also neben der Geschichte ist
Wenn du was ganz kleines brauchst ist das von eins und eins
Weil es ist eine richtig echte also eine richtig echte komplette
Voll virtualisierte VMS keine komischen
Keine komischen Container
Und die haben und die haben ein Dollar Server
Wenn ich das jetzt finde allerdings für 12 Monate ein Dollar im Monat kann man aber
Mal machen
Pricing
Haben die das nicht mehr
Ach nee war das ein Euro war das ein Euro
Also ich habe hier nämlich selbst einen Euro Server und das passt
Also ich habe zu 99 Prozent meine Sachen bei Hetzner
Und eine Kiste habe ich bei eins und eins stehen
Das schöne bei Hetzner ist es ist was auf der letzten Seite stand
Wo
Gebetet ihr mich ich sehe nur zwei Dollar
Der Chat gebetet mich
Huge, huge gebet
Ich sehs nicht
Gebetet
Ganz oben
Hör auf
Ich glaube ich glaube ich nix mehr Chat
Ein Euro im Monat genau den meine ich da habe ich einen davon
Das schöne aber an der Hetzner an der Hetzner Preis an der Hetzner Cloud Geschichte ist
Das ist minütlich also sprich hier hier musste wirklich 12 Monate bezahlen
Hier kannst du
Quasi eine fette Kiste mieten
Wir hatten uns mal hier Dedicated CPU wir hatten uns für Open Street Maps zeugs mal hier sowas
Gemietet glaube eins von denen ich glaube die fette Kiste haben wir die fetteste Kiste haben wir uns
Gemietet
Ja Google weiß Bescheid ja
Und die fetteste Kiste haben wir uns mal gemietet allerdings nur für glaube ich zwei Stunden
Und dementsprechend haben wir davon nur ein paar Euro also so gut wie nichts bezahlt eigentlich
Hier haben wir ein Euro bezahlt am Ende nach zwei Stunden
Digital auch schon ist auch nice aber digital auch schon ist doppelt so teuer
Ok
Also klappt der Kram jetzt hier genau Batterie Batterie
Wir scannen fünf Sekunden
Und jetzt Batterie Status auf Batterie Status
Sag mal hängt das scan
Leute
Hängt das Ding
Aber aber der soll der soll aufhören zu scannen nach fünf Sekunden der soll das gar nicht immer
Weiter machen mit scan
Der soll aufhören zu scannen
Warum scannt der weiter
Duration
Der soll fünf Sekunden scannen und dann gefälligst aufhören
Das ist in Sekunden und das ist in Millisekunden frag mich nicht warum man so bescheuerte Idee gekommen ist
Das in Millisekunden zu machen das sind Sekunden aber das ist so
Guck mal der hört nicht mehr auf zu scann
Und resetten
Scan start ja passt
End ja wunderbar
Ok Batterie scan start und jetzt scan end scan end
Also prinzipiell funktioniert das schon vielleicht sollte ich vielleicht sollte ich komm wir machen einfach mal
Wir machen einfach mal ein Delay
Nein ihr wisst ihr was wir machen wir machen ein Delay vor jedem Abfragen falls ich mehr als ein Sensor habe spackt das sonst garantiert rum
So ok sehr nice
Jetzt funktioniert das gut also jetzt krieg ich die Werte rein inklusive Batterie das ist doch äußerst pock
Ich krieg Licht ich krieg Temperatur und ich krieg die Batterie und das ganze quasi dauerhaft
So was ich jetzt noch einbauen muss ist ich will ja nicht jedes mal abfragen wenn ich hier reingehe ich will den Sensor
Ich will die Batterie alle fünf Stunden abfragen das heißt
Ich muss jetzt erstmal überprüfen ob ich den Sensor nicht schon gecheckt habe also
Nennen wir es mal irgendwie Millisekunden Sensor
Last
Batterie check
Aber das sind das sind das sind Microseconds jetzt guckt hier das sind Microseconds wie viel ist dann eine Stunde in Microseconds
Ah ja alles klar
Ok 5
Ah ja alles klar alles klar ok äußerst äußerst selbst erklären also sprich wenn
Macht das doch lieber als Wert in dem Sensor Objekt was habe ich doch Sensor Last Check
Also sprich wenn die aktuelle Zeit minus die letzte Checkzeit größer als das da sind 5 Stunden
Ne kleiner kleiner dann hören wir auf
Und wir müssen initial einmal
Einmal initial müssten wir sagen wenn das da
Ungleich Null ist und das hier
Gibt das halbwegs Sinn
So und jetzt sollt ihr nämlich den Batteriecheck nur einmalig machen
Du hast mich auf jeden Fall zum Programmieren animiert hast du damals Programmieren der Berufsschule in E-Technik
Haben wir jetzt ein Arduino Anfänger Kit bestellt ja das ist nice wobei ich ja immer noch die ESP empfehlen würde
Einfach weil du damit mehr machen kannst und das finde ich die beste Radwehr ist die Arduino sind aber halt robuster
Also gegenüber Umwelt Einflüssen den kannst du fast vom Balkon schmeißen da geht immer noch
Bei der IF Anweisung fehlt die Klammer
Wenn es nur eine Zeile ist darf man die Klammer weglassen aber ich gebe zu es sieht nicht gut lesbar aus
Bei einer Zeile darf man die Klammer weglassen
Du siehst es zum Beispiel daran wenn ich die Einrückung automatisch machen lasse
Vom Formatier Tool im Editor und drücke jetzt speichern dann rückt das automatisch hier unter das IF ein dass man sieht dass das dazugehört
So also es scheint zu funktionieren
Aber ein bisschen guck mal Leute das buggt seht ihr das?
Der startet den Scan und er hört dann einfach nicht auf zu scannen
Er sollte doch eigentlich nach 5 Sekunden aufhören zu scannen warum macht er das denn nicht?
Muss ich da vielleicht ein bisschen scheppere Werte rein machen keine Ahnung
213 und 217 und irgendwie 43 oder so
Ich meine das würde ich jetzt eigentlich erwarten dass der automatisch stoppt wenn das fertig ist
Und hier kann es auch kein Multithreading Problem sein weil das geht streng nacheinander alles
Das wäre ziemlich doofer Bug wenn der im Endlos Scan hängen bleibt sollte er hoffentlich nicht
Wäre ziemlich Sack
Achso Billy
Start scan
Was genau macht der Scan Part das sind die Sekunden wie lang der scannen soll
Start scanning and blocking until the scan has been finished
So genau check ich die Werte aber auch nicht
Eine Finish Methode nach dem Start bringt ja nichts die wird ja gar nicht ausgeführt der blockt ja hier bis es vorbei ist
Kifrin 17 Monate exquisite high IQ Subscription hier 17 Monate ist eindeutig schon
Exzellent Dankeschön für den Sub
So jetzt okay wir gehen einfach mal davon aus dass es jetzt funktioniert
Okay also der hat auch die Batterie abgefragt wunderbar
Irgendwo hier
Batterie 99 okay also das funktioniert der erkennt das Gerät und fragt einmalig den Batteriestatus ab und danach 5 Stunden wieder wunderbar exzellent so lassen wir das
Jetzt kommt ja der scanend ja das er kam vorher auch nur dass er irgendwie zwischendrin dann hängen geblieben ist und nicht den scan nicht beendet hat
Was auch immer da los ist
Okay das funktioniert jetzt schon mal gut das heißt wir haben jetzt alle Werte die wir brauchen
Man muss halt eine Weile scannen dass das funktioniert
So
Jetzt
Okay das heißt wir kriegen jetzt die Werte geschickt das passt eigentlich alles jetzt müsste ich den Kram irgendwie zum
Übers WLAN schicken
Wo habe ich meinen wo habe ich meinen access point hier access point kleinen test access point
Da müssen wir so mal gucken wie man die die credentials da rein bekommen Leute
Ich muss ich muss euch dann irgendwie erst mal wieder erst mal wieder umschalten
Obwohl ich kann mal kurz gucken
Documents platformer all projects was haben wir hier
CP der cool jam unter Watt jam der Watt jam war das letzte was wir gemacht haben source secrets Punkt H
Wir kopieren das jetzt einfach
Wir kopieren das jetzt einfach in den cool Champ
Cool Champ
Source secrets
Und da muss ich euch nicht nicht nicht nicht umschalten und ich habe die Sachen hier drin stehen
Exzellent
Okay also dann machen wir mal WLAN an
Also include
Wi-Fi Punkt H
By the way ich mache das jetzt alles alles mal von Hand
Ich habe mittlerweile schon eine über 1000 Zeilen lange Helper Library die ich mir selbst zusammengestrickt habe für so Zeug
Weil C++ so pains Champ ist
Unter anderem für er guckt nach ob die WLAN Verbindung noch steht und verbindet sich im Hintergrund neu und sowas
Aber wir machen das jetzt mal von Hand
Gut das heißt den Kram kann ich schon immer alles minimieren
Brauchen wir nicht mehr
Brauchen wir nicht mehr funktioniert
Wir können eigentlich könnten wir das noch mal auslagern wollte scan
Ein Bit Massive
Ein Bit
Aber das mal hier rein dass es ein bisschen übersichtlicher ist
Scan
Warum denn C++ Man kann das nicht mit was anderem gescheit programmieren also du hast noch zwei weitere Möglichkeiten
Ne bei C++ Du kannst Micro-Python verwenden
Da hast du aber auch andere Probleme
Da gibt es nicht so schöne viele Libraries für alles was man braucht
Außerdem braucht es mehr Speicher und
Ist auch letztendlich nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss
Gerade dadurch dass dir viele Libraries für Geräte fehlen
Außerdem braucht es deutlich mehr RAM
Zum Beispiel wenn du einen Web-Server machst kriegst du vielleicht 2-3 Requests hin
Gegen du glaube auf dem ESP32 mit C++ um die
Bis zu 12-13 Request oder so hinbekommst sogar theoretisch
Ich glaube sogar theoretisch sogar 5 gleichzeitig Request mit HTTPS
Ja das Nano Framework ist leider nicht so schön
Das habe ich ganz vergessen
Da fehlt aber auch ganz schön viel im Nano Framework und du hast die gleiche Treiber Problematik
So die nächste Variante ist Rust
Rust gibt es Experimental und da hast du auch die Treiber Probleme
Leider gibt es wirklich sinnvoll nur die Möglichkeit das in C++ zu programmieren
Was mir halt auch auf den Sack geht
Oh ist der Preis-Champ wieder kaputt?
Ne geht noch alles gut
Alter die Preise
Soll ich an?
Echt richtig painstampig
Okay scan also wir müssen uns jetzt connecten
Über WLAN
Das heißt wir machen jetzt Setup
Und im Setup müssen wir jetzt WIFI beginnen
Und irgendwo habe ich hier die
WIFI
SSID
Oh Mist Leute ich habe vergessen wie der Kram heißt
Ich muss euch doch mal, ich muss euch doch mal ausschalten
Wobei das, das können wir, ne Leute das können wir im Wattchamp nachgucken
Das können wir im Wattchamp nachgucken wie der ganze Kram heißt
Wattchamp
Nicht Secrets aufmachen, Main
WIFI
WIFI reconnect
WIFI SSID
Okay prima
Und ich muss das noch einbinden jetzt, jetzt weiß ich aber ob es jetzt funktioniert
Ich muss noch include
WIFI
Secret
Okay
So und jetzt können wir uns verbinden
WIFI SSID
Und WIFI Passwort
Nee PW
Oh ich hab Glück dass er das nicht anzeigt
Huge
So also von der Idee her sollte er sich jetzt mit dem WLAN verbinden
Wir checken das ganze noch mal weil
Wir gucken einfach ob er mit dem WLAN verbunden ist, solange er nicht connected ist
Geben wir einfach Punkte aus
Serial Print
Print, Brindeln
Connected
To
Und da schreiben wir jetzt
Die IP dahinter einfach
Schreibt einfach so IP
So und dann können wir noch die IP vom WLAN
IP
Okay wunderbar
So und das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren
Der sollte jetzt sich verbinden mit dem WLAN
Und mir die IP ausspucken, dass ich ausprobieren kann
Ob ich die Daten zu meiner Home Assistant Geschichte geschickt kriege
IP League, oh nein
OMFG
Du hast echt über den Preis Champ eine PS5 gefunden, ernsthaft?
Ich hab da glaube ich noch nie eine PS5 wirklich mal live gesehen
Ach so eine hier wahrscheinlich
Gabs nicht
Ach Warehouse Deal, okay
Busy, busy, busy, Delay, Delay brauchen wir noch
Serial
Print
Connecting, Wi-Fi
So
So und jetzt soll er sich eigentlich zum WLAN verbinden
Ach Alter ich bin ja auch blöd
Er soll sich nicht zum WLAN verbinden, wie soll er sich zum WLAN verbinden
Ich hab den Access Point noch gar nicht dran
Kann ich gehen
Excellent
Okay schauen wir mal zu ob er sich live verbindet zum
Gucken, dass ich nix runter schmeiß, warte mal ich leg das mal kurz neben dran
So Access Point verbinden
Excellent
Tabel
Tauschen USB-Card
Access Point
Access Point booted
Access Point booted und es sollte sich jetzt eigentlich gleich
Offisch mal collecten
Also Access Point booted immer noch
Jetzt blinkt er
Und blinkt und hat Netzwerkverbindungen
Bäm hat funktioniert
Okay
Also ist verbunden
Exquisite
Okay äußerst nice um nicht zu sagen
Okay wir sind verbunden über WLAN
Und wir fragen Bluetooth-Gedöns ab
Es gibt übrigens Probleme wenn man WLAN und Bluetooth gleichzeitig verwendet
Und das liegt darin, dass Bluetooth und WLAN die gleiche Antenne verwenden in dem Gerät
Also sprich man kann nicht WLAN und Bluetooth wirklich exakt gleichzeitig übertragen
Das heißt man muss immer ein paar Delays einbauen
Dass die sich nicht zu sehr in die Quere kommen
Sonst packts rum
Kein 5 Gigahertz? Nee
Wie kommst du drauf?
Oder war das eine allgemeine Frage mit dem 5 Gigahertz?
Nee das Ding hat keinen 5 Gigahertz
Das hat keinen 5 Gigahertz und das neue auch nicht
Es gibt jetzt nämlich einen ESP32S3
Die Benamung von denen ist ein bisschen fail
Ähm
Nee es sind nicht zwei Antennen, es ist eine Antenne
Das sagen die auch oft, das sagen die auch
Dass sie sich die gleiche Antenne teilen
Es wird Zeit, dass die Chinesen mal 5 Gigahertz machen
Achso, ja gut das kann sein
Aber ich hab letztens von denen gelesen, die sagen
Es gibt einen ESP32S3, aber der kann auch nur 2,4 Gigahertz
So, ok
Also jetzt müssen wir gucken, dass wir den Kram per WLAN
Ich hab extra hier meinen Test Home Assistant gestartet
Äh
Wie kriegt man die IP raus von dem Ding?
IP
Add
Äh
Less
Ok, More
Ist euch eigentlich mal unter Linux aufgefallen, dass less das bessere More ist?
Ok
So, äh, 2139, ok
2.13
Wait a minute
Wie?
Ach Moment, über HTTPS, ne das ist ja auch nicht über HTTPS erreichbar
Äh, 8123
Ah, yes
Gesamtverbrauch, ok das war unser Test vom letzten Mal
Das war unser Test vom letzten Mal
Äh ja, nerf nicht rum
Manchmal ist weniger mehr, das ist richtig
Das war der Test vom letzten Mal, das brauchen wir nicht
Äh, wir gucken jetzt, dass wir die Sensorwerte von dem Flora-Sensor eingeliefert bekommen
Da muss ich aber nebenbei ein bisschen aus dem anderen Projekt abgucken
Das ist die, die, die, die MQTT, Jason Syntax für Home Assistant ist etwas
painst-champig, werdet ihr gleich sehen
Aber es ist cool gemacht
Also Configuration, Integrations
MQTT-Broker und so ist alles am Start
Also das ist das, was ich auch sonst verwende für meine Heim-Automatisierung
Nur, dass ich hier eine Test-Instanz hab für rum Bastelleien
Also, das funktioniert doch alles schon mal wunderbar
Wir scannen, wir bekommen die Werte hier zurückgeliefert, alles gut
Das heißt, wenn ich mir das, diese Sachen jetzt per MQTT schicken lassen will
Brauche ich einen MQTT-Kleinwert, das gedacht
Fällt mir gerade so ein, den müssen wir ja noch
So, also
Home Assistant GUI schaut aus wie Google
Ja, die stehen voll auf Material Design
Google ist ja so, außer Google interne Apps lustigerweise
Google selbst steht ja total auf so Material Design Geschichten
Außer die YouTube App und Google Apps selbst, die nehmen es dann nicht so eng
Okay, Leute, wir haben jetzt zwei Varianten
Wobei, ich hab's eigentlich vorhin schon beantwortet
Ich hab gesagt, wir machen das diesmal selbst
Ich kopiere mir keine Helper-Geschichten und
Wir machen's von Hand
Also, ESP32-MQTT-Publish-Example
Also, es gibt zwei Varianten, was man jetzt machen kann
Man könnte entweder eine fertige MQTT-Library verwenden von GitHub
Gibt's beispielsweise AduiX
Pubsub
Könnte man nehmen, aber
Man könnte auch das eingebaute nehmen
Wie viel Flash ist voll mit Plutus, WLAN und MQTT?
Tja, aktuell sind wir bei
66%
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung
Da ist sogar noch Platz für einen Web-Interface
Um Firmen zu verwenden
66%
Wohlgemerkt, 66%
Ich hab schon die
Die File-System-Partition für
Random-Dateien schon verkleinert
Also, wir haben 1,9 MB
Für den Kram
So
Espressif
Die haben doch
Wie schreibt man die?
Espressif
Ja, irgendwie so
Ich brauch Beispiele
Ich brauch Beispiele, wie der Kram funktioniert
MQTT
Over TCP
Jawoll
Du, du, du, du, du
Du, du, du, du
Leute
Das ist doch einfach
Ich hab keinen Bock das nochmal neu zu programmieren
Ich nehm einfach was
Was ich schon mal gebaut hab
Wo ist es denn?
Ach hier
So
Tack
Müsste eins passen jetzt
So include
MQTT
Client
Wunderbar
Passt
Also es ist wirklich nicht viel
Das ist nur so ne Mini-Wrapper, den ich mir gebaut hab
Um die Native MQTT Funktionalität
Von dem Kram hier
Was wird gemacht?
Wir lesen den Sensor aus
Nämlich so ein
Und den Sensor den benutze ich nicht
Für nen Plumptopf, wie das gedacht ist
Sondern für nen Kühlschrank
Lichtsensor für Tür auf
Temperatursensor für
Temperatur, ne
So
Ähm
Leute
Wartet mal kurz
Ich hab was vergessen, es kann sein einer schweckt muss
Keck wait
Leute ich muss weg